if I take your car you no longer have
your car if I sing the song that you
wrote you still have your song that's
exactly why we have copyrights so you
can turn a profit
I am Nikolas be with reason TV and today
we're talking with Jerry Brito he's a
senior research fellow at the Mercatus
Center and the editor and a contributor
to the new collection copyright
unbalance Jerry thanks for talking with
thanks for having me okay you've edited
this great volume from ER Cadis about
copyright law
give us a brief history of copyright
terms and wire why do we need to balance
copyright I mean your title says it's
unbalanced well the reason that the book
is called copyright on balance is
because what Congress is supposed to do
with copyright is strike a balance
between giving creators artists authors
enough of an incentive so that they will
create but not anymore
the founders when you know they ratify
the Constitution 1789 with a copyright
clause in it and the next year in 1790
they've themselves with the first
Copyright Act and what today deemed it
was enough of an instead of 14 years
renewable for 14 more for a total 28
years total and you have formalities
which mean you had to register for
copper to ask for you to get
automatically now everything is
copyrighted you know your book
copyright on balance your contribution
is why conservatives and libertarians
should be skeptical of Congress's
copyright regime conservatives and
libertarians tend to talk a lot about
property rights and they get confused or
that the terms that copyright has been
debated within conservative and
libertarian movements is wrong they
think to themselves I think it's a very
honest mistake to make they think
property is good we like property it
allows free markets to work copyright is
property it is there for more and longer
and stronger copyright must be excellent
and a problem there is a copyright it's
a different kind of property its
statutory property it's created by the
Constitution it doesn't predate the
Constitution the way common law property
works so it's more akin to Admissions
permits taxicab medallions right these
things are very valuable their property
they're tradable they're dividable you
know but they're completely created at a
creature of of statue right and the idea
also that I mean
copy or you know what created work if
you put out a CD and I make a copy of it
it's different than real property in
that even whether the my copy is
authorized or not you still have your
copy in full use of it if I did that
with your house you would have one of us
would be out on the street if I take
your car you no longer have your car if
I sing the song that you wrote you still
have your song and so it's a bits that's
that's exactly why we have copyright
because we do want to give you some
exclusivity some reason some way to
exclude others so you can turn a profit
talk a little bit about the the central
role that Mickey Mouse seems to play in
copyright legislation yeah so Mickey
Mouse
every time the Mickey Mouse has been
about to fall into the public domain and
he is about to become a character like
Uncle Sam or Santa Claus or Hamlet right
just you know owned by nobody Congress
passes a law that extends the copyright
and that's crazy because you can't
possibly incentivize Walt Disney to
create Mickey Mouse again number one
because it already exists and number two
because he's dead how do we change the
copyright regime you talk a lot about
the politics of the book you talk about
in the in the book the Stop Online
Privacy Act which was a recent attempt
to really kind of force ISPs and people
to cough up a lot more information that
copyright infringement it seems that
when people can copy things easily in
unauthorized ways they will so is this
really just gonna go away because people
can copy whatever they want first to
Stop Online Piracy Act I think what that
showed when you look at the coalition of
people who got together to fight that
back a lot of it came from Tea Party
activists the first people the first
members of Congress to abandon Stop
Online Piracy Act were all Republicans
who went down with the ship to the
bitter end defending SOPA was Al Franken
what was arguments he was making is a he
would say I'm a Screen Actors Guild
member and I'm protecting the jobs of
everybody in Hollywood but of course
that's not the point of copyright so to
protect jobs I think businesses
industries are gonna have to adapt and
you know they're gonna try to rely on
the law in the short term and and that's
understandable in part because you know
some folks are violating the law when
you're winner pirating but in a long
term they're gonna have to adapt final
question do you do you have unauthorized
copyrighted materials on your computers
you know I think it's impossible for
anybody today
to have that way the laws are written
fair enough
oh then you are a lawyer I think that
came through loud and clear there but
we've been talking with Jerry Brito
editor of copyright imbalance he's a
senior research fellow at the Mercatus
Center I'm Nick Gillespie